so much what I think about is how people
love to save time and how much I value
your time and how much empathy I have
for your time and so we are doing more
mashups of some of our best keynotes you
just may not have an hour and a half to
get it all and so I'm super excited
about this little mashup right here and
I'm also very excited because this
keynote also led to the the Dec the PDF
the the presentation about how I make
content in today's world so this is all
very meta for me this was a obviously a
very special day that is that has led to
the ability for me to communicate to you
about ways you could be doing it for
yourself but most of all wanted to make
sure that all of you got the themes of
this special talk
positivity and offense always wins
historically always the reason I spend
my time on talking about this is not cuz
I want to be a [ __ ] motivational
speaker and fluffy-fluff fluff and rah
rah rah it's because it's the [ __ ]
thing it's nothing
life is binary it's either offense or
defense when you bet on optimism when
you're on the offense you do something
SuperDuper interesting you start
suffocating excuses if you ask me the
number one thing I wake up every morning
and thank that my parents did is I never
saw either one of them complain about
jack [ __ ] and it basically created
learned behavior for me I'm incapable of
actually complaining about [ __ ] and that
has become the foundation of my success
yes it is absolutely difficult for all
of us we all have stuff do I believe
some people have it do I believe a white
male has it more approachable yes I do
here's my problem my problem is if
anybody has ever done it with your
circumstances then you have nothing to
talk about
in the mindset that I want for you to
win everybody's in a slump like
everybody's got adversity there's always
something to me somebody's always got it
worse there's 7 point 7 billion people
and unless I'm in some weird little cage
in some fourth world country that means
I'm not in last place which means I have
nothing to complain about like you live
in America
[ __ ] are you complaining about
we have it the best and all I see is
people sitting around and dwelling
around dumb [ __ ] around what they don't
have instead of focusing on what they do
have a lot of us were born with what we
were born with right like you're only so
pretty they're only so smart you're only
so fast you'd only like you're only what
you are it's like a great poker player
right a great poker player doesn't need
the best hand every time to win it's how
she or he navigates with that hand we're
not gonna change who we are or where we
were born or to whom we were born with
but no matter where you are in the life
cycle right now we all have the
opportunity to start looking at a little
different and to me very frankly I just
think we spend an enormous amount of
time on dumb [ __ ] when we have ambition
to do so much more when I was nine years
old and opened the door for an elderly
woman at a McDonald's she reacted as if
I won the Nobel Peace Prize what my mom
did was super smart she overreacted on
everything that I was doing that was a
good human trait and she held me
accountable for things that didn't
matter like grades she didn't let me
complete like she punished I got
punished four times a year every year
from the time I was in third grade until
my senior year of high school my mom
built huge self-esteem in me and I feel
like the biggest reason I am Who I am
today to everybody is because I feel so
guilty and so grateful for what she did
for me that I want to do it for
everybody else I promise you if you want
to be pumped professionally and
personally there's one thing that will
drive you to the biggest success it's
called self-awareness and I want that
for every [ __ ] person because let me
tell you something
[ __ ] is the best it's such a good
place to be when you can get to that
place amazing [ __ ] happens you know why
cuz you stop being scared when you're
not scared you do [ __ ] when you're
scared you do nothing
look what are you scared up like what
your dad's gonna be like I told you
you're a loser what are you [ __ ]
fearful of like your sister making fun
of you because she's got a better job
[ __ ] her cool like don't forget my
friends you could be winning 28 nothing
at halftime and lose so your older
sibling that's got a great [ __ ] job
could be a crackhead next year could
could because he's had a whole facade
the whole time [ __ ] trying to suck
your parents dick right and and he's
actually insecure inside and something
went wrong at the office and he starts
[ __ ] doing coke on the side like guys
don't you understand how this is played
this is why I'm petrified of [ __ ] 8th
place trophies if you grow up where
everybody gets an eighth place trophy
you are actually scared of losing and
then you're [ __ ] because losing is
real I love I swear on my [ __ ] kids
health
I'm obsessed in tweezing I [ __ ] love
music I love losing because I know
exactly what you're thinking about my
loss and I can't wait to stick it in
your [ __ ] face when I come back I
recommend [ __ ] up on purpose I'm
being serious
it's so much better to like eliminate
expectations from the gap then you're
playing with house money if you're
scared of other people's opinion [ __ ] up
on purpose then everybody thinks you
suck [ __ ] that it's all upside you suck
at a ton of [ __ ]
so does everybody else you're also
probably pretty [ __ ] rad at something
tries many things as possible until you
figure out when you're rad at and you
like and go [ __ ] do that for the rest
of your life and stop giving a [ __ ]
about everybody else figure out whose
opinion is dictating your actions beside
yourself like it is in my mindset that
literally every negative thing that
happens to me is my [ __ ] fault
literally your ability to be the bigger
man and woman in every situation even
though 9 out of 10 times you may be
right
is the variable of your success both
within an organization and compounded
when you go out into the real world and
this takes me back to where I started
please understand the following being
nice is ROI positive one of the biggest
reasons that a lot of you don't do the
right thing is because you expect
somebody to do that in return after you
do it and that expectation of the reason
I'm good is because I give with zero
expectation return a lot what works for
me is I do it for the right reasons I'm
all-in I don't mind if I lose I actually
weirdly prefer it and if I do great for
you and then I need you in a year and
you don't deliver I'm cool with that too
I'm empathetic
maybe you're maybe you didn't get it
maybe you're not a good person maybe
you've got some [ __ ] on your mind right
now that didn't allow you to come
through I think the expectation of
others and the opinions of others are
disproportionally guiding your life and
I think that you will end up regretting
that in your older years
[Music]
so go [ __ ] up
[Applause]